I'm Dr Brian kopel neurosurgeon today
I'll be answering questions from Twitter
this is brain surgery support
[Music]
if fianel asks what does the brain feel
like to the touch if tofu and Jello had
a baby that's how the brain feels
there's a a give to it as a patient
breathes or the heart pumps blood the
brain pulsates accordingly at Stony P
asks did you all know that you gotta be
awake for brain surgery when you're
operating on areas especially related to
language we literally ask them questions
some patients have played instruments to
demonstrate that they are doing okay I
have had a patient play a guitar in my
operating room we want to see when we're
trying to do a surgery for Tremor which
is a rhythmic oscillation of the hands
or the feet the patient be able to drink
from a cup or sign their name which are
things that they were not able to do if
you stimulate and the patient's still
able to respond they can repeat a
question they can repeat a phrase that
tells us that it's safe to go forward I
aren't they screaming in pain the answer
is no the brain in of itself has no pain
receptors at Blake and band asks what is
harder rocket science or brain surgery
well that's an easy one to answer brain
surgery is harder consider that there
are a hundred billion neurons in the
brain the amount of connections between
those hundred billion neurons are
greater than all of the stars estimated
in the universe that's why it's harder
at lightning Anthony asks do brain
surgeons practice on fake rubber brains
before having a crack at the real thing
no we learn on the job the very first
time I walked into an operating room I
was struck by the smell we use electric
quartery that is electricity in order to
control bleeding in the brain in essence
what you're doing is cooking flesh and
well human beings have a very particular
smell when they are being cooked that is
a pretty eye-opening or nose opening
experience the first time you go into an
operating room it would be very hard to
replicate it even the best simulation
technology isn't quite the same at least
currently than the operating room itself
at lechem V asks just watch the
resection of a brain tumor bro how do
neurosurgeons do it and it was done
perfectly the skill must be crazy Nature
has inconveniently placed the brain
inside a box called your skull and
trying to get into that skull is like
pulling off a heist you have to get into
the brain not cause any damage remove
the tumor and get out leaving the
patient no worse than you found them
depending on the tumor it can look very
very similar to normal and healthy brain
and it takes an experienced eye and some
new technologies for us to see in the
operating room where tumor ends and
where normal brain begins sometimes
because the tumor is particularly soft
we would take it out piecemeal by
suction a suction is essentially a metal
instrument that's a straw that also has
ultrasonic Energy Applied to its tip
that helps the suction along once all
the bleeding is stopped we essentially
then close the covering on the brain
which is called the dura fix the bone
flap back to the skull let me close the
scalp and we get lunch at Lydia bohaya
asks what happens if you need to sneeze
during awake brain surgery or do they
give you something so you don't sneeze
sneezing is often accompanied by
something called a valsalva maneuver
where the pressure inside the brain
temporarily spikes and then goes down
again I do deep brain stimulation
there's a relatively small hole that's
made in the skull about the size of a
dime sometimes when a patient sneezes or
coughs you can actually see the brain
pulsate up a little bit that can
potentially be a problem but it's pretty
rare at willmium asks how do they fill
the hole in your skull after brain
surgery the most common way that we fill
that hole is with the patient's own
skull we usually affix that piece of
skull called a bone flap back to the
rest of the skull with titanium mini
plates sometimes we have to remove a
piece of skull permanently very often
this can be in the setting of trauma we
used to do this with titanium mesh so we
would get a essentially like a screen
door bend it into place and affix it to
the rest of the skull to cover the hole
more recently we can get a CAT scan of a
patient and computers can design a
perfect plastic replacement for what we
removed that looks just about as good as
the real thing at darkwise asks why do
most brain tumors trigger food smells
are brain tumors delicious sometimes
tumors can create seizures in the brain
and depending on where the seizures
arise from can involve smell Associated
oil faction Associated areas of the
brain very often these smells are
actually bad smells so it is a very very
unusual to elicit a hallucination that
is a good smell but it can happen at
Kazu Dingus asks if I was doing brain
surgery I would Swirl My Finger through
the guy's brain just to see what happens
I mean dear Lord really running a finger
over the surface of the brain if you're
very very gentle will do very little if
there is pathology near the surface the
brain surface can be friable where just
the nearest touch can cause bleeding but
a healthy brain can be touched with very
little recourse at zeldovitz Lauren asks
why were lobotomies ever a thing
lobotomies were not only a thing they
are the only instance where neurosurgery
ever won the Nobel Prize in the early
days of the 20th century psychiatric
care was extremely rudimentary there
were many many patients
institutionalized it was a huge burden
for families John Fulton a physiologist
at Yale discovered that the frontal lobe
was really important in creating the
manifestations that we associate with
psychiatric disease egas Monet
speculated that if we were to interrupt
certain fibers inside that frontal lobe
that we could in fact help patients an
instrument called a leukotome is
inserted into the brain and then a hole
was made inside the Deep portions of the
frontal lobe once Thorazine was invented
the use of lobotomy as a treatment for
psychiatric disease fell out of favor
but
the whole process actually helped
mankind really truly understand the
physiology of psychiatric disease for
the very first time that psychiatric
disease was not a weakness in a
patient's soul but a real disease like
diabetes and actually led to a lot of
understanding and treatment that we are
using today at dibs on Debs asks hearing
the term neurosurgery seems to have such
a different connotation than brain
surgery do they have the same meaning or
are they entirely different entities the
term neurosurgery encompasses brain
surgery so when we all become
neurosurgeons we actually learn the
entire surgical technique of treating
surgical conditions of the brain the
spine and the peripheral nerve which is
the entire nervous system brain surgery
is just a segment of neurosurgery itself
at go Blue tsunami asks what is a
craniotomy a craniotomy is a temporary
window that we make in the skull in
order to allow us to access the inner
contents of the brain to remove a brain
tumor or to clip an aneurysm we start
off by placing Burr holes or small holes
around the periphery of the window that
we intend to make we then take a type of
Saw called the craniotome and we
essentially connect the dots or the
holes and we create a window called the
craniotomy itself do not try this at
home at Gladstone writer asks for brain
surgery on the way for me this time my
neurosurgeon is going to go through my
nostrils it's a procedure known as
endoscopic endonasal surgery so one of
the areas that we encounter tumors and
other types of pathologies is in the
pituitary gland at the very very bottom
of the brain and it sits inside this
little bony pocket called the pituitary
fossa at the very back of the nose sits
these Pockets called air cells inside
the skull itself and so by inserting a
tube and a camera through the tube we
can unroof this air our cell and we are
right at the pituitary base and we can
take out a tumor without having to
disrupt normal anatomy of the skull one
of the more common restrictions is
limiting the use of things like straws
that can develop a lot of suction inside
the air cells while the the healing
process is occurring and yes also don't
blow your nose at Chris Conway asks what
clothes do brain surgeons wear cerebral
Gore-Tex hahaha I start off by wearing
my surgical scrub hat I also wear my
scrubs over the scrubs are the sterile
layer of our Garb which involves an
operative gown and a pair of surgical
gloves and this whole process of gowning
us up in a sterile fashion is assisted
by either a scrub nurse or an or Tech
once we are garbed completely we can
begin the operation at Peggy Trill X did
you know when they do brain surgery and
need to remove part of your skull for an
extended period of time they just cut an
incision in your abdomen and put it in
there sometimes there is so much
swelling in the brain we have to give it
room so that patients can survive the
injury we have to remove the entire side
of a patient's skull for a long period
of time ultimately if you want to be
able to put that skull back it's got to
remain sterile and what's the most
sterile place for for a patient's body
part their own body what you're
referencing is something that is falling
out of favor but is still done
neurosurgeons would make an incision in
the abdomen and place the bone flap
inside this temporary pocket and close
it up and as long as there was no
infection of the wound that bone flap
remained absolutely sterile at that
Ricky dude asks so I heard somewhere in
random conversation and I'm not sure if
it's true he was having brain surgery
and the doctor poked something and he
remembered being at a party many years
before in Vivid detail well in fact this
did happen during an operation called
deep brain stimulation the electrode was
going to be placed in a part of the
brain called the hypothalamus the
trajectory went through a structure
connecting areas of the brain involving
memory called the fornix a patient being
awake on the table
recalled a series of events from their
childhood and the amount of detail was
so striking to both the patient and the
investigators and the surgeons they
developed a technique to stimulate this
particular area of the brain and have
created trials looking to help patients
with Alzheimer's disease at Rock Cox 64
asks you know how during brain surgery
doctors will have the patient play the
violin if they're violinist or whatever
so that they don't up their brain
do you think that they would have a
gamer speedrun Super Mario 64 during
brain surgery if they're a famous this
video game athlete I suppose why not we
could do that sure no problem that
billionaire asks I just seen a billboard
for gamma knife brain surgery where
apparently they operate on your brain
without cutting anything open the gamma
knife is a type of what we call
stereotactic radio surgery pinpoint
beams of radiation are focused deep
inside the brain and wherever these
beams of radiation intersect they
deposit a therapeutic dose of radiation
that's in a very important tool
especially in the realm of certain
vascular disorders brain tumors and
certain functional disorders at producer
Danny ask hi yes can a brain surgeon
weigh in here and tell me which part of
my brain is responsible for getting the
Jurassic Park theme song stuck in my
head I'd like to remove it please well
that would be a really bad idea because
the controller of attention is called
the thalamus it's a deep area of gray
matter inside the brain and it actually
Acts as a gate as to what is grabbing
our attention from moment to moment to
moment I highly recommend keeping your
Thalamus at Danielle babe 26 asks is
deep brain stimulation surgery worth the
risk so like the heart the brain is an
electrical organ everything that we do
from writing a Sonata to hitting a
baseball is the result of an electrical
pattern of activity in the brain
diseases such as Parkinson's disease or
dystonia or things even like depression
and obsessive-compulsive disorder are
the results of abnormal electrical
patterns of activity in the brain what
is deep brain stimulation essentially
what it is is a pacemaker for the brain
we could place an electrode through a
very very tiny hole at the top of the
skull into deep structures of the brain
what we are trying to do is take a one
millimeter electrode and hit a one
millimeter Target inside the brain so
it's really really really super precise
by regulating that electrical activity
we can actually make patients symptoms
much much better the scariest risk is
bleeding in the brain or stroke
generally around one percent I had Big
Daddy on air asks a robot which can
perform brain surgery was showcased at
the hashtag world robot conference how
good are you at your job robots are
coming to take it away well believe it
or not robots are already in the
operating room there are some
limitations one the skull itself and
other areas of the body where robots are
used such as the abdomen robots have a
lot of access because the abdomen can be
temporarily inflated with air and
there's a lot of room for robots to move
around skull's inconvenient there's a
skull and then there's a brain not much
else and so robots to really become very
useful for brain surgery they're going
to have to be miniaturized to a huge
degree furthermore somebody's got to
tell the robots where to go and that
still will likely be a human process for
for many years to come at fiend Mrs the
brain does not feel pain as it has no
pain receptors if that is the case why
do we experience headaches I have severe
migraines and feel like I have an ax in
my brain sometimes in the case of
migraines the blood cells constrict and
then as the blood cells begin to relax
that physical relaxation stimulates the
pain receptors and causes the pain at
leemerg xrl asks can a brain surgeon cut
open my head and take out the pieces
with ADHD please thanks there are some
non-invasive brain stimulation
techniques called transcranial magnetic
stimulation that people have explored
for ADHD but not neurosurgically as of
yet at quetzal cohette asks how do you
choose the area of the brain where the
electrodes are implanted we place an
electrode inside the brain to interact
with networks of the brain and networks
of the brain are distributed pockets of
neurons that are all working together to
create a behavior if we're talking about
a network function that's related to
Movement we are interested in placing
these electrodes in movement Associated
areas of the brain deep gray structures
called the basal ganglia which can be
seen over here other avenues of research
are looking at placing electrodes along
the surface of the brain to stimulate
the network along the cortex because
everything is connected even though
you're stimulating locally you're
affecting things globally at pristine
Martian asks how far away is superhuman
intelligence with a brain computer
interface I think currently we are
fairly close to having brain computer
interfaces really help a process called
neuroplasticity in the brain and
neuroplasticity is the brain's normal
process to learn and adapt to the
outside world I think that's something
that we're going to likely see within
the next several years the idea of
having a a Bluetooth implant in the
brain that helps you Google something on
the Fly we are talking decades upon
decades before we would see something
like that occurring so those are all the
questions we have today great questions
thanks for watching brain surgery
support
[Music]